こんにちははじめ社長です
最近コメント欄に多いんですけど
読みます
前髪どうした前髪どうした今日前髪鬼太郎何度も頭のカミキリませんか
枚組の相席で一面中を傘べさんに見に行きたいの前髪どうした髪伸びたなぁ
なんか久しぶりではじめみたら髪の毛厨二病みたいで草生えたはじめ巻きってほしい
個人の意見です久々に初めて来たんだけど髪の毛を退いた髪型どうしたってことかね方
ちょっと癒さ
いつもの髪型にやってるマジ髪の毛来て欲しいはず
めっちゃ髪伸びてるじゃん髪切ってください切実はじめ髪の毛切って髪切ってください
というですね私の髪型についての意見が最近コメント欄で非常に多くみられております
たしかにたしかにこれはもう誰がどう見ても髪の毛伸びすぎですねー
北戸会の下あからさーん
じゃあさすがにといううざうざんですよ本当にあの指すんですね僕も何の意味もなく
こんな金がないしてるわけじゃなくてちょっと意味があったんでちゃんとそこは伝え
ましてください
なぜ僕はこんな髪型になってしまったのかというよりいつもなんかアイロンとか航空肉
出かけたりあーマっぽくアイロンかけたりして中をごまかせなんですけどもちゃんと
伸ばすと後年
くらいの長さですねもう全然髪の毛よねー
くれるぐらいの長さに当たってるんですよねたという長さですとりあえず今日はですね
なんで初めは最近こんな変な髪型になってしまったのかというと説明をさせてください
いるのはそれからにしましょう
なんで僕この片方の枚組だけどばするかと言いますですねふとしたことから始まって
しまいましてとある映画の主人公が髪の毛のこっちだけちょっとはなかったんですよ
fantastic ベストっていう針
とった系列の映画があるんですけどもそれに出てくるミュートっていう主人公が
めちゃくちゃカッコ良くて僕イギリスに留学いくらちょっと英国紳士っていうものに
憧れててあっもうあんたってくれると見た瞬間ん
new トっていう主人公になるべくなりたい近づきたいと思って new とは猫の
髪の毛の片方だけ長くてパーマーかかってなんて旅行感覚があっていい
av の中実はめっちゃかっこいいでその時まだ前髪が全然なかったので髪の毛切る時
に相談したらじゃあもっと長さを伸ばしてな傘を交わしてからパーマかけたらあれ
ぐらいになるよって言われてそこから僕は前髪を伸ばすようになりましたその片方だけ
なぜならニュートリになりたかったからでせっせせっせと伸ばしなんですけども私ある
日気づいてしまったんですよ
髪の毛切りに行った時に一言言われたのが髪の毛がいた b すぎてて
palmer かけれない完全に new と終了のお知らせでしたの知ってる方は
知ってると思うんですけど僕一回ここらへん
もうこれ見たらわかると思うんですけどもコンチョ茶色くなってる部分
ここかつて金髪だった部分なんですよ bleach 5回くらいしますあぁ片目隠れ
てればいいな
その張って延ばして延ばしたんですけどもう伸ばしてる部分がもうブリッジ後6回しっ
て
パーが書けたらぐちゃぐちゃのぶじょぶじょに物議寝ちゃうよって言われてそこで僕は
のニューと性格終わったなったもチョップ止めてたんですよ
でも結局けど結局ないんでちょっと気に入っちゃっててかっこいいですよねこれやって
みてね皆さんがを取りか知らないよ皆さんはこれをかっこいいと思ってるか知らない
けどちょっと注意をかじっている方からするとですね片目隠れてるとかっこいいですよ
踊ってないの
結構州でかっこいいと思ってるんですよそのセンスを疑わないでください片目が考え
てるアニメキャラ結構いるじゃないですかあの
ディゼロの霊夢ちゃんとかさーこ糖分の花指の蜜鳩がいるじゃねーか片目隠れてる
キャラということですよ
アンティ目の世界なんですよそことの葛藤で悩んだ結果僕はこの髪型でいることを決め
たんですそれもちょっとパワー駆けで彼のごまかす程度になんですけどもう最近の
コメント欄は本当に前髪どうしたどうしたとさ
切った方がいい切ってほしいたくさん意見をいただきました本当にありがとうござい
ます
僕もそうだと思いますいや本当に同意なんですけどもなんか
せっかく
ここまでこんな伸ばしたことないサブ踏まえのにせっかくだましたら伸ばしたくなっ
ちゃいませんか皆さんそうでその結果
こんなことになっているんです僕今配布し切れたよねあんたスティックリストから
始まり中二病に終わるすぎなもんですよ髪の毛てただ僕はこの髪型にして気づいたこと
があるんですよたいていの人は単発が好きだということに綺麗でしまいました
なんか変なんだろうなブーブー
変なんでしょうねあと目にも悪いしねここだけめっちゃ日記3できるってホント辛いで
風吹いたらめっちゃコンパチバチバチた新しいもいいことないとかもしれないという
わけで今日のこの場を持ちまして前髪を切らせていただきたいと思います
いやーやっぱりでも目によくないねほんとに目が悪くなりそうだし良いんだから
花のみち海を越えちゃう絶対イチローと思いますで考えどうやって着るかと言いますと
もちろんただ普通に着るわけじゃないですちゃんとちょっと u 2がぽい口をして
真似しようと思っておりますこちらに20面ダイスがありますこれ一から二重の数字が
ある大豆ですね僕とこちらの髪の毛長さ測ってみたんですけどもに元からカルト18
9000つくらいでちょうど20センチくらいなんですよ
山田これベストだなと思いまして廃頃のでためセンチ部前髪切ろうと思いますはいでは
早速ググっていきましょう
一発をでいきましょう本当に良い一発で辻沿いですよ
もう
まあ最終決断を放すだけは切れていたのは皆さんですからねぇ
今スプーンあって本ファイバ夜のバイナリー
今
たい
ん
[音楽]
ai
me
うううう
male
me
me あった
こういいなぁ勧誘を
これがこうだったわけですからね
あーこれっ